all right so michelle obama who i'm
repeatedly reminded is
charismatic and deeply likable though
i've yet to find any evidence at all for
this claim
released a video on behalf of the biden
campaign where she lays into donald
trump
calls him a racist liar but in the
process of calling trump a liar she
herself
lies with impunity especially when it
comes to defending the violent
marxist radicals of blm here's some of
that
portion of what she said listen they're
stoking
fears about black and brown americans
lying about how minorities
will destroy the suburbs whipping up
violence and intimidation and they're
pinning it
all on what's been an overwhelmingly
peaceful movement
for racial solidarity it's true
research backs it up only a tiny
fraction of demonstrations
have had any violence at all
so what the president is doing is once
again
patently false it's morally wrong
and yes it is racist
but that doesn't mean it won't work
because this is a difficult time a
confusing time
and when people hear these lies and
crazy conspiracies repeated over and
over and over again
they don't know what to think with
everything going on in their lives
they don't have time to fact check
falsehoods
being spread throughout the internet and
even
reasonable people might get scared and
the one thing this
president is really really good at is
using
fear and confusion and spreading lies to
win
patently false morally wrong and racist
that's how michelle obama describes
donald trump but she may as well have
been
speaking into a mirror instead of the
camera because her words apply
much more to herself she says that the
protests quote unquote have been
overwhelmingly peaceful and that only a
tiny fraction have had
any violence at all how does she know
this well research
she says research backs it up i just i
love it when people cite research
not actual research but just the word
research search
like what's your evidence for that that
claim you just made oh
research yeah the research all the
researches
oh and evidence too research and
evidence that's that's how i know
just that's it research and evidence now
she doesn't of course go into specifics
so i could only assume
that the research she's talking about is
the much belly-hood study from the armed
conflict location
and event data project this uh which
which did a study about this summer's
protest
and its findings were trumpeted by the
mainstream media with headlines like
this one from the guardian saying
nearly all black lives matter protests
are peaceful despite trump narrative
report fines and what did this study
actually find well it says according to
the guardian
the vast majority of the thousands of
black lives matter protests this summer
have been peaceful
with more than 93 percent involving no
serious harm to people or damage to
property
now already there's a a problem with the
serious harm qualifier
what counts as serious harm and why
shouldn't the supposed
non-serious harm still be included as
violent
i mean if you punch me in the face and
barely manage to get me a nosebleed
does that mean that your punch wasn't
violent or does it just mean that you
have scrawny toothpick
arms and you punch like a child now
in any case let's just go with this
research for a moment for the sake of
argument
and say okay seven percent it also says
that between may and august
there were seven thousand seven hundred
hundred and fifty blm demonstrations now
what's
seven percent of seven thousand seven
hundred fifty i'll let you do the math
mainly because i'm too stupid to do it
but i do know that it's several hundred
so by these very favorable calculations
trying to put things in the most
positive possible light for blm
still we are left with the conclusion
that there were several hundred violent
blm demonstrations that involved
serious harm to people property or both
in the span of one summer this according
to michelle is a tiny fraction
i wonder would she still consider
several hundred violent demonstrations
in the span of just three months
a tiny fraction if these were maga
rallies descending so frequently into
looting an arson
would seven percent be a tiny fraction
of say pro-life rallies that involve
torching abortion clinics would seven
percent be a tiny fraction of
fecal coated chocolate chips in a
chocolate chip cookie
i'm just trying to figure out when seven
percent becomes tiny
is it only for blm violence i'm pretty
sure that if
that if i were to say only a tiny
fraction of people who've contracted
covid have died from it
michelle will take issue with that even
though the fraction is far
far far less than seven percent
yes it would seem that seven percent
becomes tiny only in a very selective
and politically useful circumstance
so michelle obama or anyone else on the
left defends
mob violence as somehow peaceful what
she
and they really mean to say is that in
their minds
the violence doesn't matter or perhaps
is even justified
this is something to to keep in mind
when you listen to another message from
the binding campaign also from yesterday
this is from joe biden himself
who went to gettysburg in a bit of a
self-aggrandizing stunt
to give a message on unity and here's
what some of that sounded like if for
some reason you want to hear it listen
here on this sacred ground
abraham lincoln reimagined america
itself
here a president of the united states
spoke of the price of division
and the meaning of sacrifice he believed
in the rescue redemption and
rededication of the union
all this in a time not just
a ferocious division but of widespread
death
structural inequity and fear
of the future and he taught us this
a house divided could not stand
that is a great and timeless truth
today once again we are a house divided
but that my friends can no longer be
we are facing too many crises we have
too much work to do
we have too brighter future to have a a
shipwrecked
on the shoals of anger and hate
and division yes unity we must have
unity not hate
not anger and division but remember that
for the democrats
rampaging through the streets looting
throwing a molotov cocktail at a cop
none of that counts as anger and
division for them
unity and peace may include burning down
the local cvs and this is precisely why
all of the happy talk about
unity the speechifying the empty
gestures towards it
all of that is meaningless and can never
bring about true
unity because as i've argued in the past
we are as a nation
divided on such a fundamental and
foundational level all the way down
at the roots of our being that unity is
simply not possible to unite we have to
unite around
something in something for something buy
something because of
something unity for unity's sake can
only ever be shallow it can't be lastic
it can't be real
but we live in different universes now
as americans
not even two different universes this is
like a multiverse situation everyone has
their own
we are unmoored from reality and truth
and biden and the democrats
they want us to unite in their universe
a universe where blm radicals torching a
police station are peaceful
and where babies aren't people and where
men are women
and where college graduates have a
god-given human right to have their
debts paid off
by appropriating funds from those more
successful than them or even less
successful
and so on all of their calls for unity
should include that disclaimer yes come
unify with us
in our universe in our reality
and that i simply cannot do it's not
even that i won't do it it's that i
can't
i also won't but i can't so where do we
go from here
where does that lead us well i don't
know exactly
but the happy talk isn't gonna help us
and certainly the lies from michelle
obama and others
won't either hey you uh yeah
you you're right you're right there hit
the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated